[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jean claude van damme est avec nous
que je suis pas
oh là là juste m
oh là là q comment
je suis pas naïf
[Musique]
ap
jean claude van damme c'est long
jean claude jean claude jean claude job
et en ce moment
s
jean claude van damme
merci rejoignent en en direct comme des
fous de t'avoir je suis fan de toi ouais
je sais que je ne regarde que tes films
sur la tête de ma mère je suis comme un
merci merci beaucoup
frérot comment quel beau gosse on a
déconné s'y arrête je te jure et je suis
comme vous
jean claude van damme une légende
commence à mamou jean-claude ça va bien
et je suis content de te voir et
jean-claude c'est que moi c'est que je
fais un truc tout le temps parce que toi
je sais que tu aimes bien à faire tout
le boulot car tu dois quand même gagné
rien n'est pas jean claude van damme lie
à jean-claude maquereau ou de mon frère
pour le faire seulement côtoient ouais
je sais bas attendait un attendait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors être c'est quoi jean claude tu
veux te propose un petit jeu comme si tu
veux on va voir celui qui lève la jambe
le plus haut avant ça je rappelle que
j'aimerais que tu as fait l'émission et
benjamin castaldi tu l'a reconnu tout de
suite d'ailleurs quand à des règlements
et elle n'a pas changé est toujours
aussi beau ah ouais c'est vrai et aussi
c'est qu'on est en année ça fait quoi
mais voir cette image où jean claude
darque as tu sais qui tu l'avais des
cliniciens moi j'adore non tu dis non
non pas du magasin dit j'aimerais que je
sais que matthieu delormeau vous faites
des arts martiaux soins alors jean
claude est ce que tu peux refaire le
coup pied mais sur matthieu delormeau
pour voir alors également j'aurais voulu
demander quelque chose à jean claude
mamet l'arrêt calme-toi déjà un vrai me
donne ma troisième et d'après lewis
hamilton et cyril c'est qu'on est fous
de lui alors comment me donne une autre
lumière comme il doit le tenir parce que
alors comment mais je m'en tiens
meilleur et pas sur bizarre parce que
c'est mon médecin et mon métier basta
blanc attention d'accord en vérité en
puissance c'est pas terrible d'accord tu
ne mets pas trop on est loin des poncifs
qu elle attend les championnats aussi
attention kahn aurait près à la tête à
la caméra et c'est bien
la vache oui mais comme ça tu fais tes
yeux et celle après l'agencé pour la
cascade dsk l'a puni mots pour amener
quelqu'un au soleil
allez merci à eux
jean-claude franchement je te dis tu es
une carrière exceptionnelle
moi je suis fou de toi et ce soir je
suis très très heureux que tu sois là
pour les 9 ans de tpm pays jean claude
van damme est avec nous je vous dis dans
un instant une séquence qui va devenir
culte je suis sûr et sain
[Applaudissements]
manas la n va
enfin en instant d'ailleurs on leur
montrera ce que vous avez toujours rêvé
mais arrêts lui aussi chez sais quoi et
le coup de boule de la vue mais c'est
pour ça tu m'as dit elle et harry been
coudboul me changer je sais qu'hier soir
avec nous